good morning good morning is the morning
show here in classes here 6,500
kilometers from London brexit is on the
Morning News the beaches of Anguilla in
the Caribbean are not that far away from
the European Union in fact they're in it
and asleep you know from the European
Union so how will it break the defectors
the popular radio host DJ hammer reaches
many of Anguilla's nearly 15,000 people
and they're asking the same question
just across the channel is the French
part of San Martin the islands have long
enjoyed close relations but that may end
with Britain's exit from the EU we
fighting because we're being affected
directly in the angular see Martin Bora
has been a sophomore for years three
years and you know and we are we are
concerned that you know that doesn't
present a situation but in fact that in
a negative nearly all of Anguilla's
goods and supplies are imported from the
larger neighboring French island on
boats like this the British Island has
to bring everything in even drinking
water this port is the lightness of fine
work it's the only the car this is the
only cargo port so if for whatever
reason this port closes own angular and
itself just my clothes now
since Hurricane Emma devastated the
island in late 2017 demand for
construction materials has been high
very many buildings were destroyed the
school was hit hard hardly any of the
classrooms are still usable so principal
Joyce Webster steward says classes are
held in shifts half the children come in
the morning and the other half in the
afternoon
King comes you board up and you go in
and get shelter not thinking that the
place where you going in is what's gonna
be knocked down that needs a shelter
when I saw it it was heart-rending it
was broken
the plant reconstruction is funded by
the EU which is also Anguilla's largest
provider of development aid much of the
funding a potential 14 million euros is
earmarked for education but after brexit
nothing is certain when I travel to the
United Kingdom I would say 90% of the
people that I talked to who are British
I have a clue that there's a place
called angle so you know I really think
be an afterthought I don't think there'd
be a big on the agenda of the British
government as one of the issues that
they speak about the Islanders are
afraid that should London fail to secure
the brexit deal at wants and needs
Anguilla will be among the biggest
losers they'll lose their development
aid their EU passports and the open
border to the neighboring islands a
chance to participate in the brexit boat
and that no other people should decide
on grants fate but then Britain has been
increasing her micromanaging of anger it
puts us in a precarious position because
economical we might be a disadvantage it
does not make us feel as though be a
part of British territories is it fair
to us that means we has no say because
if you take the economy of Angola and
you take the budget of angular it has to
be approved by England so we are just
puppets in the air and he and Williams
were not allowed to vote in the
referendum their frustration over brexit
has reached the point where some are
calling for independence from Britain
DJ hammer is for it we can't borrow when
we chose to borrow that our hands are
tied
you know I'm did you find it to be a
little bit demeaning go for other people
again and again DJ hammer hears from
people who are angry often fishermen and
restaurant owners like a red gums they
need close relations with our EU
neighbors but none of the Islanders
knows for sure what the future will
bring so they completely get alienated
and when you eliminate people they
always will take back an action the
action more and more and Williams would
like to take is independence if they had
been able to a majority would have voted
to stay in the EU now many would rather
be part of the EU than a Britain